mentioned that one of the victims in the
attack was Mike Hill he was a custodian
at the Covenant School for close to a
decade and a half and he was a big part
of what made this school feel like a
family we've heard it from everyone
I'm joined this morning by one of Mr
Hill's friends Pastor Jim Bachman you
were a founding Pastor here at the
church Mike was a dear friend of yours
tell me about him father of seven
grandchildren to nearly a dozen
grandfather to me yes yes it was a great
a great man he was a custodian
but a friend I was a senior pastor
I'm white he's black
it didn't make any difference we talked
about faith we talked a lot about his
love life
we just we got along famously everybody
loved Mike Mike knew the knew the kids
in the school knew their names and took
a very personal interest in them and
whenever he saw my kids who weren't
students at the school but but he'd give
them a big hug and so Mike was one of
those people you could not not like you
were here when the property to school
the church everything was built you know
that upstairs where the shooting
happened when you arrived this morning
you told me that you heard that the
shooter was initially going for the
current Pastor trying to find him can
you tell us more about that I don't know
if that's been confirmed or not but I
heard he went into the office suite
which I remember that's very that area
very well and apparently the some of the
staff
they just had a safety uh or shooter
drill the week before so that's
fortunate
so they they were hiding and I think the
Pastor Chad Scruggs was not presents
what I've heard
and then the shooter turned and went
back down the hallway to the second
third grade classrooms the shooter you
knew in second grade what do you
remember not much just another sweet
little second grade girl that was
competitive like to play sports with the
boys and came from a wonderful family
and she was a very sweet girl Pastor I
want to ask you I've heard so many
people say lately faithful people I
don't want your thoughts and prayers I
don't want to hear about thoughts and
prayers on what action as a man of Faith
you will conduct Mike Hill's funeral
next week you will preside over it what
do you say to those people who say that
well I haven't decided yet but I'm sure
I will what about we don't need your
thoughts and prayers we need action what
do you say to that you made action from
who the police or laws that restrict
these types of guns or gun laws that's a
little bit above my pay grade I think
what I say is we need to love each other
and we need to learn to disagree
agreeably and learn how to forgive and
you know people from different
ideologies different theologies
different backgrounds
it's okay to disagree but it's not okay
to shoot each other and particularly
shoot children and innocent victims and
so the message of the Gospel is we love
our neighbor as ourselves and try to
Bear each other's burdens and work
through the whatever problems we all
have problems and you know we all we all
need help at times in our lives and so
that's part of my my job to try and help
those situations thank you for showing
up yes sir God bless you appreciate you
thank you thank you
Tony before I toss it back to you I want
to show you one thing that we saw
yesterday and it's Carolyn monitor she's
101 years old and she walked up to the
memorial yesterday and followed the
Covenant even though she didn't know
many of the people there she said quote
at my age 101 maybe it's a little
ridiculous for me to be here
but I just had to come one of many who
have shown up to pray
Tony
yeah David I can understand it a lot of
people are thinking about Nashville
right now we do so much to protect our
children in this country we put padding
on playgrounds padding on the cornering
of the table but when it comes to guns
it just seems our urge to protect it
falls short it breaks down and I'm not
sure why I guess it's above our pay
grade as well guys I don't think it's
ridiculous at all that she wanted to be
there everybody feels that they want to
do something but I think we have to say
something about those police officers
yes there's been so much negativity
about police officers in the news and
and just uh on the air and to hear these
two officers Rex Engelbert and Michael
Collazo if you haven't looked at that
three-minute video that's been released
it's riveting my heart started racing
because these guys clearly had a system
they ran as soon as they heard gunfire
they ran to the gunfire Nate there was
no hesitation knowing that their lives
were in Jeopardy and I think the
majority of the police officers behaved
the way those two do yeah and it shows
the important work that they do oh yeah
danger and and that is what courage is
exactly exactly no thank you again for
your reporting from Nashville